all right guys
bang bang i've got two special guests
today i've got kate namir here thank you
guys so much for doing this
yeah thanks for having us good to be
here absolutely let's just
uh kind of go through both of your
backgrounds maybe kate will start with
you uh kind of what you do before you
get to the information then what do you
focus on there
yeah so i've been at the information for
almost a year now and before that i was
a reporter at techcrunch where i
covered startups and venture capital i'm
on the same beat
at the information covering a lot of
early stage startups
covering a lot of fintech covering all
the venture capital funds
awesome and amir so i was
for nine years at the wall street
journal covered all sorts of things uh
including white-collar crime and then
later technology um
not that there's a lot of overlap but um
then uh helped to to start this this
publication the information
um which is led by jessica lesson who
was a colleague of mine at the journal
and we worked really closely together
uh so uh i still work for her i
started to work for her uh when we uh
when we launched the company in 2013
and um off to the races and
awesome and so you guys recently put out
this list the 50 most promising startups
uh maybe let's just talk through kind of
why focus on a list and then what was
kind of the criteria and how did the
list come together
so we wanted to focus on more under the
radar
startups there are plenty of companies
that are getting wild
wildly high valuations very very quickly
in their life
um and then others that are that are
choosing to take a different route and
maybe not raise
as much money probably because they're
really good businesses to begin with and
they don't need the money but there are
plenty of
um young companies that we wanted to
spotlight in really important areas
that perhaps just don't get enough uh
just don't get enough light
and for me personally just speaking
personally there are a lot of
examples in the kind of enterprise
artificial intelligence
realm essentially companies that are
helping
companies other companies make better
use of their data
uh or prepare that data for for machine
learning models to process them and
improve different you know aspects of
the businesses that they operate
um so there's just a lot of action a
tremendous amount of action
and we wanted to focus on companies that
have raised
about a hundred million dollars or less
uh in some cases very very little z
zapier um in enterprise software zapiers
are our favorite there
they've only raised uh 1.5 million in
equity
and debt and they are definitely one of
the most interesting
enterprise software companies in the
world um and very few people have heard
of them because they just stay super low
um and then uh in some cases you have
companies that have raised a lot more
than that so we
we extended our parameters for this list
of the most promising startups to
companies that have
raised um uh that have launched uh three
years
or or less so companies that were
founded three years or
or or less so that that's our um yeah
that's how we that's how we did it and
really we we you know we just get a lot
of really good response when
we focus on metrics uh
of these companies how startups are
actually performing a lot of very young
startups
get attention but we don't really know
what their growth rates are what their
revenue is
what are the challenges challenges that
they face
and we just really wanted to hone in on
that we get a really good response when
we do it
and so is it fair to say that uh the 100
million dollar
uh in capital raised mark in the three
year mark that was your attempt to
define a startup because it seems like
you know when wework was like 15 billion
dollars at one point it would be like
startup wework
and it was kind of hard to see like
where does startup end and do you become
like a real company
i don't think anyone really knows where
startup ends i think for me i still
consider
companies pre-ipo fair game if you're
like a startups reporter
but yeah i think our goal is there is so
much noise in the market right now i
think
more than ever even during during the
pandemic when you would think
startups wouldn't be doing as well and
so we thought if we spent a couple
months
like looking through hundreds of
companies we could probably come up with
a list and confidently say
these are the startups that are actually
truly startups early in their
lives that you know we think that our
audience should be paying attention to
got it and kate you've
obviously focused a lot on fintech
there's a number of fintech companies on
the list kind of what are you seeing
there are there any specific companies
that stick out to you as
uh companies that people should be aware
of and kind of paying attention to as we
go into 2021
yeah i mean all the companies that we
put on the fintech list i think is about
eight are
amazing companies um i will say it was
really difficult to
narrow it down because every company
right now is
is is a fintech company in some way and
it's kind of the joke that the fintech
investors will say
is like every company is a fintech
company so like how could you shoot how
can you choose just five or ten
um and i tried to pick you know
companies that sort of represented the
ecosystem which is um
diverse in terms of like companies that
are and what they're doing whether
they're helping small businesses whether
they're creating a virtual card or
whether it's
something like robinhood and one of the
companies on this list
actually it's called trade republic and
it is very similar to robin hood it is
essentially robinhood targeting the
european market it's already doing
phenomenally well and you know
growing really really fast um so i would
say
my big takeaway was you know the fintech
market is enormous right now
there's more money than ever has been
going into that category
um going into it from venture
capitalists and i think that there are
just
so many different uh problems that these
entrepreneurs are trying to solve and
hopefully they're not you know competing
with stripe which is the monster
that pretty pretty difficult to defeat
right now
absolutely and emir obviously when you
look at from the investor standpoint
kind of who the big winners on the list
are
andreessen and sequoia both kind of lead
the list in terms of their number of
their portfolio companies on there i
think
sequoyah had eight and andreessen had
seven uh is this
a product of uh the best get the best
deal flow and therefore that should be
expected or is this just them proving
you know this is why they're the best is
because they're finding companies that
uh that either others can't get into
or uh where they're picking the right
winners well it should be mentioned that
a few of those
from sequoia are actually from sequoia
capital china so we had a
part of this list about 10 or 11
companies are
based in china and i think sequoia
capital china was it was in three of
them
um and jurisan was actually more
interesting
uh and jason horowitz was more
interesting in in the in the grand
scheme of things here because
um they yeah they invested in some of
the companies that are
that are based here and they they don't
have like a
like a you know chinese cousin or
chinese version so
it was it was andreessen horowitz proper
and you know they they really stick out
because they have
a couple of partners uh one of them is
named martin casado
probably be great to have on pod um who
really focus
on uh enterprise software but with a
machine learning bet and they really
understand how the ecosystem how there's
this ecosystem
springing up of different tools to help
data scientists or machine learning
experts
um make you know make their companies
better um
and they've been investing in this in
this area for for years and there are
some
other firms that are a bit um you know
they invest a little bit in the earlier
stage like
data collective as juan or custo noah
ventures uh is another
um that also do this um and the so
andreessen in this case has
has really uh kind of been ahead of
ahead of the curve
uh in in many respects so um i i
i can probably pull up some of the the
companies that they invested in that are
that are on our list but um but yeah
they really seem to have the kind of ai
space which i realize is very hyped up
um
and we're not talking about general
artificial intelligence or anything like
that we're talking about much more basic
uses of machine learning that can
actually make a difference to companies
that are not named
google or facebook or amazon and so on
i think also oh sorry i was just going
to say
another takeaway for me seeing sequoia
and andreessen on this list so much is
just these firms i've gotten really
aggressive at
seed in series a really early stage and
we've talked about that a lot
um and you know you're seeing it pay off
these these firms obviously have the
best deal flow because they have the
best reputations
they're not new to this um so i think
that was
interesting to see i mean they're
clearly in the best companies already
they don't just do
you know those big rounds those growth
stage growth stage investments
absolutely uh two of the companies that
were on the list that i thought would
just be fun to talk about one is a cameo
and the other is a bunch
with cameo we've had stephen on the
podcast and it seems like they've really
kind of
gone from what i think a lot of people
looked at as almost like a toy at first
right it was like what do you mean
you're gonna pay for like these videos
to now all of a sudden he's you know on
twitter talking about like we're gonna
help people monetize their time
uh and do it with the most famous people
in the world how do you guys evaluate
that type of business and and
you know how much of that is uh hey
they're just getting started versus
they're already a pretty big company
they've raised a lot of money and and uh
we're kind of seeing what they'll look
like in that final state
well we were we were surprised to
to hear that um you know their kind of
gross
sales are going to hit 100 100 million
dollars in 2020 and that
means that they are going to take in on
a net revenue basis 25 million dollars
that did surprise us we didn't realize
it was that big however
um you know another company that came up
which is a very unusual
company um whose founder you should also
have on is only fans
and there is gonna be a merge here
because
uh only fans is also monetizing people's
time and they have a long tale of people
including
you know people in the adult
entertainment industry of course um
who who are doing that cameo started
with you know uh
mainly kind of b-list c-list celebrities
um some of whom are lovely people some
of whom are
criminals um you know from from the
tiger king um
and they uh yeah they there's definitely
going to be an overlap here and you're
right it's one of those companies
that at first you you think it's kind of
like jokey and
cute and then you know over time uh
and then you know certainly somebody
like like steve
realizes what what's happening and what
the possibilities are so we
we definitely like it um we we think it
has a lot of potential
but only fans grow sales this year i
think are going to be 2 billion
so um that's really going to be the big
fish
in this market of monetizing people's
people's time so
i think cameo is very very focused on on
only fans and there's of course room for
multiple companies to to exist in this
area yeah i think we'll see
cameo i mean the company's only worth
300 million i say only because
that's a valuation that actually
surprises me i think they'll be
north of like 1.2 billion probably in a
matter of weeks
because they're probably in the middle
of fundraising because everyone is
so that'll be interesting to see kind of
who which investors go after cameo and
make it into their next round absolutely
and then what about a bunch
in terms of kind of a different type of
business but what are the thoughts there
that was a much simpler calculation i
think
you know you have the service called
discord for
hardcore gamers right to talk to one
another
bunch is and it's a very young company i
think like
watched like three years ago that's just
a community-based chat service for
mobile games
so it's the mobile game version of
discord
and you know games in the pandemic
period
i mean it's uh you know my colleague tom
talks a lot about it just
such a such a good business um and and
this is
obviously one of the areas that's just
taken off and bunch has just benefited
from that tremendously
so i don't think that was one of the
companies
uh one of the few companies i don't
think we had revenue data for
for for the 50 companies that we wrote
about i think we had revenue data or
growth data on
at least uh 40 42 43 of them
and um we did not have uh
revenue for for bunch but um
i actually think they may be pre-revenue
let's see um yeah i think that that was
that was probably the case i don't think
they've
monetized yet so that was that was an
issue but their
their user base um is is growing
tremendously
and uh i think it's just a
you know tom my colleague tom daton just
calls it a no-brainer
and the plan is that they're going to
generate revenue through in-app
purchases
you got to customize the experience that
people have with the app and add
features in terms of how they chat with
one another
and then eventually the company is
looking to do kind of branded content
and events
in the in the app but it's really just a
bet on mobile gaming taking off and
that's a great bet to make absolutely
some of these decisions were a lot
easier than
others i think that's probably a good
example of one and there were a couple
on my
fintech category that were more
straightforward but i think especially
when you see some of these that were
just accelerated so much by the pandemic
and i
bunch clearly you know people playing
more games people looking for that
social interaction
that company i imagine i didn't do the
reporting on this company but i imagine
has grown quite a bit
during covid so that coupled with the
fact you know
that discord has done so well i think
makes it pretty makes it a pretty
obvious choice
yeah one of the things that stuck out
and amir you mentioned it earlier um
is that about 20 of the list is in china
and so um there's been tons of debate on
twitter obviously of like you know what
founders and investors are leaving in
leaving san francisco uh moving to san
francisco who's going to la miami austin
you know we can go around the world
almost tulum right the whole nine yards
uh talk to me
both about just like geography in
general should people read into the fact
that there's twenty percent of list on
uh from china um and does that play into
some of this more like mobile type of
workforce
uh just giving kovid and the lack of
need to go into an office or kind of how
do these things all relate to each other
it's two separate thoughts and kate can
talk about the the u.s
side of this we've always been focused
on china we have a four-person team
in hong kong that focuses on chinese
companies
and there are a lot of very good reasons
to do that it set us up very well for
the rise of bite dance which runs
tick-tock
which is just a version of a of you know
a service that they already
have in china it's massive and
we we cover all the biggest companies
there you know alibaba
and you know up and comers like
pinduoduo which is another huge
e-commerce player
but on the on the startup side we're
also able to
to follow uh all of the trends that
you know oftentimes they start in china
and then they end up around the world
especially when it comes to kind of
innovative business models uh you think
about
you know monetizing video that is
something that
companies in china did very well uh
you know much earlier than companies in
the west did and
it's it's really similar with with every
other type of business
what's interesting right now with
respect to the chinese companies on our
list of the top
50 most promising startups is that a lot
of them
are enterprise businesses they are not
consumer businesses the the
action in china right now in the earlier
stages of venture investment
um have very little to do with kind of
consumer
startups there are some kind of direct
to consumer startups in the in the
commerce area
people who are going direct and selling
makeup or selling other goods
but a lot of the action is in things
like robotics
or you know marketplaces that help
companies
find designers to help them create ads
or branding
um there's there's you know certainly
a category of company that is using
advanced forms of machine learning to
diagnose various illnesses um you know
looking at
uh you know looking at you know x-rays
or or other health data and coming up
with
um you know coming up with a better idea
of
what's actually wrong finding some
patterns and then
industrial robots is really the the core
area that we focused on in in this list
so many companies are developing robots
for various purposes whether they're
uh aiding warehouses and making
warehouses more efficient
or they are actually aiding in the
testing of new drugs
such as or vaccines in in the case of
covet 19. so
there's just a lot of action there but
kate can talk a little bit about
what's happening in the bay area which
is definitely as you pointed out the
hottest topic on
on twitter and i think um uh
you know i think we take a little bit of
a more measured view but when i was
hearing about
people like drew houston who runs
dropbox leaving the bay area
i you know it's hard not to take notice
you know it's it's not
it's not just because people are looking
for tax shelters or
states like florida and texas that don't
have you know state
state income tax it's a it's definitely
a bigger issue that
that has taken off during combat but can
you talk a lot more to that
yeah i mean half of our list was san
francisco bay area companies but i don't
think that that's any indicator that
you know san francisco is is going to be
any
is going to be less important in the
future like we don't know yet
because people are leaving now so we
won't if we do this list in
four years we'll have a better sense of
like okay how significant is the bay
area but um
i think it's undeniable at this point
that the debate is is
fair you know early in the pandemic when
i was asking questions about
you know people abandoning san francisco
i got a lot of responses that were like
no they're not going anywhere why would
you ask that or or
this comes up every year it's not a
story and and now it's clearly
a story and people are talking about it
yes on twitter
but um also offline and people are
moving to
for some reason miami and austin have
really well because of obviously tax
purposes but
miami and austin have really become the
hot spots and i think every day you see
more people doing it and i know i've
spoken to people who don't want to share
online that they're doing it but they
are moving um
so i mean i think it'll impact the san
francisco bay area i think
what will happen is most companies that
are
very very very early will still want to
build
in bay area because there are just um
higher density of entrepreneurs and
investors and i do think that will
probably stay true
but i think anyone that is experienced
or
later stage in their company um you know
somebody that's sold a company and just
is well connected there's probably not
going to be a big reason for them
to be in the bay area long term and i
think that's kind of what a lot of
people that i'm talking to
are agreeing on yeah and what's so
interesting i think
is um there's obviously the tax
conversation there's like a weather
conversation if you will
um as i look in it's snowing out here in
new york and
it's not snowing in uh uh san francisco
but
also it seems to be like there's a
critical mass conversation as well right
it's like yes some people in the early
part of this adoption cycle might have
moved uh for taxes or because of
covet or whatever but now like where's
the tipping point right
like how many people have to move to
austin or have to move to a miami
before it becomes like that's just the
same thing as moving to san francisco
five or ten years ago right because it's
just like this critical mass any
thoughts there
is it a number of people is it certain
types of people like if all the vcs move
then all the companies move or vice
versa
like how do you just think about like
what makes this a sustainable trend
versus maybe just something that's
happening
uh during covid i mean i think it's a
hard question to answer and i don't know
because we haven't really seen it happen
um in the past you know we've seen
conversations about second-tier
hubs you know you have seattle you have
atlanta but we've never seen those
companies reach a
point of maturation that you know comes
anywhere close to the area
i suspect just because of the history of
san francisco you may never really have
something
comparable but you know if you imagine a
scenario in which
every key investor is no longer
in the bay area there may be less of an
appetite amongst founders to move here
but then you know you still have these
accelerator programs that in theory will
probably go back to in person
um that are connected and there are a
lot of people who actually like san
francisco a lot and don't
want to move so i guess i have a hard
time really imagining a scenario where
there is this huge tipping point of
enough people being in austin texas
which is so different from san francisco
that it really becomes like some
replacement
of sf but that's kind of just my
personal take
it's got great barbecue and cheap beers
though so you know that's their selling
point
go ahead a hot summer i i think it's
important to talk about
the distribution of employees and how
that's going to change
and there are there have been companies
zapier actually the company i mentioned
earlier
and and for people who don't know like
it's a little bit um
it's a little bit difficult to explain
but it's basically software
that kind of helps make the connections
between different types of applications
so that they can talk to each other so
if you want to like
automatically save every email
attachment you get to dropbox
or you want to send all of your human
resources forms docusign
zapier helps you do that um so they're
they're pretty critical
you know under the hood type of service
they
started in 2011 they are one of the
oldest companies on our list
they um have always been i mean
the three founders are based in the bay
area they all
moved out here and they were actually
part of the y combinator uh
accelerator but they uh have
hired people in a distributed fashion
they're they don't have an office
they don't think they've ever paid rent
so
there are going to be more companies
like that and cameo you mentioned steven
earlier
they have become officially a fully
distributed company permanently
so they are planning to just
you know hire people remotely from here
on out now
not every business can do that if you're
in the robotics realm and you need
people in a
you know specific area if you're
developing autonomous vehicles or
whatever it is
yeah you need like a group that's
together there's
you can't replicate that virtually very
easily so we're just going to see a lot
a lot more of that and companies have a
lot of incentive to do it it's much
cheaper
to do it this way you can run a company
much more efficiently and be much more
profitable faster if you do it this way
so
i think that's actually a bigger driver
of
of kind of what what we're all talking
about here there isn't
a cheaper way to do business than there
ever was so
i think that's really going to going to
drive it people see what's possible now
some of that will continue we don't know
how much will continue but definitely
some well i think what you're saying is
like as those companies scale too
and they really do need to hire a lot of
employees that's really when you need to
go elsewhere but i think maybe the
really early days and like the
you know going through y combinator
raising your first round maybe where san
francisco is still a really significant
and important ecosystem but yeah as you
as it gets more and more expensive
why not go elsewhere or go fully remote
absolutely and in terms of um if we kind
of think it from the investor seat
there's two
things that i think are happening right
one is obviously there's uh this move
from
hey i want to meet people in person warm
intros all that kind of stuff to now
there's this more like
digital first world making investments
across zoom
i think that that's like pretty well
documented and most investors will
maybe they thought that was going to be
a big deal seemed to kind of have made
the transition just fine
um but also there's been a whole bunch
of
i'll call it gyrations and valuations
because it seems like certain sectors
are seeing
an explosion in valuations and maybe
other sectors that are becoming less hot
or not and so how do you guys think
through this comparison between public
markets and private market valuations we
were
joking before we're recording this on
the day that uh doordash
just went public and literally if you
refresh the page like every 20 minutes
they've added like billions of dollars
of market cap um
so how do you just think of like that
valuation component in the private
markets and compared to the public
markets
i mean both are both both are incredibly
robust um
robust is a great is a great word to use
there yeah so i mean
you know as we all know public markets
do help determine private market
valuations and you're seeing both
reached kind of insane levels i mean i
just was talking to a seed investor
before this call
who said if you are an alum of robin
hood stripe
or any other airbnb perhaps like you're
going to
get a valuation of like 30 million to
100 million with um no product or
you know hardly an idea and even if you
are somebody he said
that's that's someone experienced but
maybe not an alum of one of those
companies you're still going to command
a pretty high valuation so that's what
we're seeing like from seed
all the way to pre-ipo which is i mean
we
stripe is reportedly raising at 100
billion
valuation like i don't know i think it's
it's hard to imagine that it's going to
persist uh through 2021 like this
but with that said i think it will so
i'm really curious to see where
evaluations go
next year but um but yeah i would just
say both are
really crazy right now it's confusing
they're of course the the macro economic
issues here where you know interest
rates and inflation
play into play into what's happening in
the public markets
but i think because of
what has happened especially with
companies like
google and facebook and apple and amazon
i think a lot of the assumptions
a decade ago that all of us in the press
and and many investors and many
operators had
about how big these companies could be
with the core businesses that they had
were just way off they ended up having
markets that were much much much bigger
and you know you have some similar
arguments being made now especially with
regard to enterprise software cloud
software
cloud infrastructure people like aaron
levy you know the ceo of box
who's excellent tweeter if you don't
follow him already
you know talks about this all the time
and i i think there's
there's definitely some truth to that
there's also you know that what's
different about the
private markets in tech versus the
public
is um is also just a very limited
group of companies that have traction
that you can invest in
and there is an incredible willingness
right now
on the part of a lot of the money that's
chasing
private tech deals to just be out of the
money for
a while in the sense of putting money
into work at these companies
at a supremely high valuation and just
not worrying about it for a while even
if it seems like too high of a price
hoping that it'll work itself out
there's just so much money chasing so
few deals
and maybe that's what you're seeing with
with doordash right now people just want
to park their money somewhere um
and it seems like a good spot but we you
know we wrote this story
not to belabor the point wrote the story
about the 100x club
which is the software startups that have
these incredible valuations despite you
know little to
to no revenue uh especially in the in
the cloud-based software
world uh companies like you know loom
which is a video communications tool and
postman and and some others i mean even
notion you know with the productivity
software app that you probably have
heard of
um has a has a pretty lofty lofty
valuation
um and and yeah i just think it's a
really unique
period of time and i i you know
i don't think any of us can say whether
it's ridiculous
or not i think doordash at 72 billion
valuation
that requires a lot of profits to make
sense and i don't
know that that they're they're close to
showing us those profits so
so as you guys think about um kind of
the winners of 2020 um i've seen that
you've
uh published a couple of pieces just
around like the venture capital returns
and some of them were
company-specific so like i think airbnb
i saw one where you kind of went back
and said who invested when and
kind of who's going to profit the most
uh but also just for the year 2020
how do you guys think about the big
winners and it seems like andreessen and
founders fund uh and sequoia again kind
of come up
in conversation there but just what are
the thoughts and and kind of how do you
see that yeah i mean we just did a piece
on the vc winners and it's
very clearly this year founders fun in
sequoia so
it's not it's the usual suspects it's
not surprising but it is amazing to see
these firms kind of like
landing on top with in sequoia's case
you know a 20
state and multiple of these
multi-billion dollar ipos
we calculated at least i think around 15
billion in returns and that's not
including you know
the way that these companies are popping
day one and i i'd have to be updating
that story every minute
to to in real time tell you what
sequoia's returns are
but but yeah i mean i guess there wasn't
really it wasn't surprising to see
who we did see on that list it also
included ggb capital
and some others that had just really
lucrative early stakes
but again i think the lesson is just
this multi-stage strategy you can see it
play out in real time for sequoia
they've gotten a lot more aggressive
early stage they've even gotten you know
they're getting more aggressive
across all stages and that's how they're
really
maintaining such huge stakes um and
again just
getting in early that's really the most
important and if you can get
the seed and airbnb you know you're
gonna make a lot of money
absolutely amir anything dad yeah i mean
we pointed out that they
had a chance to lead the series c
deal for airbnb on top of the other
rounds that they led but they were
acting too slowly and brian chesky at
airbnb got got pissed off and went with
went with founders funds so that
definitely costs them
cost them a bit but just to hammer home
this point that kate made
venture firms or private tech investors
are going earlier and earlier and
earlier and
paying more and more and more in terms
of prices and increasing the sizes of
the rounds
and you know tiger tiger global is
um is one of the firms that kate's
written about um a lot that it's being
super aggressive
another is co2 management it's like
hedge fund that also does a lot of
private tech investing
you know they're actually very um very
competitive with one another and
they are chasing early stage deals like
crazy
because they they want to get into the
next you know
airbnb or what have you or snowflake as
soon as possible
um and that's just that's having a
massive massive impact on the private
stage
which is crazy because those are
multi-billion dollar
hedge funds turned venture capital funds
that are like i mean they're literally
going after
three million dollar financings and and
and not even
they're not necessarily winning i mean
sometimes they are of course but
co2 is one that we've seen i i believe
more active than ever
maybe you know maybe they were just as
active last year but before that not at
all
and in these super super tiny early
stage rounds and
some you know initially it was confusing
to see so much of that but i think we
understand when we see these ipos and we
see these stories kind of
come to an end for these not you know
not necessarily an end but like kind of
we can understand why seed is
as competitive as it is now
absolutely and it also feels like
there's this um
belief you know take the hedge funds for
example like they have all the public
market data they should be able to see
things that venture capital funds might
not see
or uh you know hey if i'm gonna buy the
company on the ipo why don't i try to
buy it in the round before
and you saw you know fidelity and a
bunch of these people doing that and
then they just kind of work their way
down
uh it is surprising though to see the
three million dollar kind of
seed round right to to imagine that a uh
a multi-billion dollar hedge fund uh is
competing at that
uh stage but again if you get in at that
stage then you kind of have an
option on you know information and uh
you know kind of first rights
um or at least first look at a lot of
things that happen to the company uh
from there
i want to end uh talking about stripe
it's come up a couple of times in
conversation
uh they seem to one have built like the
elephant in the room
uh but two they also seem to be bucking
the trend and not interested in going
public at
all uh i saw today somebody tweeting uh
calling spax
uh spac po now which is just you know
the uh the most recent way to get to the
public markets but it seems like stripe
has no interest in that they're raising
uh money that's been reported
uh at very high valuation how do you
guys see that business and
is this kind of a once in a generation
company that we can expect you know one
day to be in kind of the
the conversation with apple and amazon
and others
or kind of how do you look at this yeah
i think so i think it's a
once-in-a-generation company and i think
patrick and john colson's
line that they've been giving out lately
is just that they're in the first inning
and they don't want to go public
as such an early stage company i mean
they're incredibly mature they have what
like a dozen
well-developed products um and
compete with everyone in fintech
ecosystem but
they do have a lot of access to capital
and i
imagine that there are many many
investors who are going to continue to
be willing
to give them those pre-ipo dollars and
eventually
i imagine they will go public i mean we
saw palantir was what 20 years old when
they finally ipo this year
stripe is i think you know pushing 10 i
think they recently
turned 10. we may not see them go public
for five or six years i i think it
probably will be sooner but
i'm not holding my breath i think
they're they're taking their sweet time
they know they have
many many options it depends on how many
of their
employees they they let sell sell stock
and kind of relieve some of that
pressure through secondary sales and
others
and kate i'd be remiss if i didn't
mention your excellent story about
stripe also being a fantastic
venture investor in and of itself which
i think i think matters here too right
yeah i mean it shows you how how
incredibly mature this company is i mean
they they're at the point where they're
essentially a corporate venture capital
fund yet
but yet like we discussed earlier kind
of still a startup right like we don't
really know what they are they've kind
of created their own category and
i don't know if investors are readily
admitting it but they are
beating out venture firms big ones
for deals in infant tech companies and
in companies founded by stripe alums and
i know there are many deals i don't know
about
there are many i do know about i think
they are just very active
and i don't see why we're gonna see them
slow down i know john
colson recently um did an interview
where he said
um they're they can they plan to
continue doing investments and their
goal is to grow the gdp of the internet
which is a very broad
statement that i don't you know could
really mean a lot so i think we may even
see them
become a little bit more um more
generalist outside of fintech
uh patrick and john coulson also angel
invest two we saw them do rome which was
that note-taking app that
has gotten a lot of attention um and
they valued that company at
200 million and that was a company that
was
just launched its product so yeah it's
really interesting for me i think to see
a company like this behave like a
venture capitalist and do so many things
at once
absolutely i want to uh leave the
listeners with
2021 predictions if you will is there
one thing that both of you
either believe is going to happen in
2021 uh or
paying attention to something that other
people could color a lot from from
watching
well i can speak to things like mobility
and autonomous vehicles
for instance you mentioned spax earlier
and i think we've already seen a couple
of
lidar sensor developers
go public in that way velodyne and
luminar
velodyne's revenue was shrinking when it
went public
luminar does not have revenue uh
and their facts both did very well um
uh in in relatively speaking so luminar
is worth two billion dollars on paper
now
so yeah this is a pretty unique period
of time and i think
that for especially some of the weaker
players
in autonomous vehicles that are trying
to develop prototypes that work
you will see you will see some of those
go out next year
as facts and try to tell a story whether
it's in automating semi-trailer trucks
or you know small little sidewalk robots
or even passenger vehicles which
obviously there's not a huge market for
you know uber type services but it will
come back and
they will they will try to make their
make their case
uh so i think you'll you'll see a lot of
that um for for those
of your listeners who have teslas or
care about tesla which i imagine is a
lot of them
um you know this this whole
quote-unquote full self-driving
uh bent by elon is i think
a pretty misleading uh
type of marketing to do because these
cars are not
ever going to be fully self-driving if
the
person who is behind the wheel is
actually responsible
for the behavior of the car so that that
is something that i'm focused on you
know there's this beta
out for for people to test this full
self-driving software on
city streets as opposed to uh highways
where
uh tesla autopilot features were you
know automated steering and braking were
first launched
now they're trying to do it on city
street so those are some of the things
that
that that i'm watching uh in particular
um yeah i definitely have some my editor
recently told me that my 2021
predictions were not very interesting
and that is because
i suspect a lot of what's happening now
is going to continue
like i think you know we saw record
investment we saw record fundraising i
think we're going to see it again
um we saw a company we saw these sectors
be accelerated by covid
edtech remote work software financial
services i think we're going to see that
continue
um the only thing i have to offer that's
maybe a little bit more unique is i
think
we will see perhaps a record year of
fintech exits i mean we do know robin
hood
um is is planning i think a q1 ipo
there's others like chime that are ipo
ready
and i know that there are fintech
companies that are very interested in
going this fac route and you know
ribbit capital which is amongst the best
fintech firms
has their own spec so i think we'll see
a lot there but otherwise i really think
even getting a vaccine and even say the
second half of next year is like normal
i still think you know even pre-code the
venture capital ecosystem the startup
ecosystem was doing phenomenally well
so i just suspect that it'll continue in
that direction
absolutely that's fantastic uh i ask
everyone the same two questions before i
end it uh the first is what is the most
important book that either of you have
read
in our lives yeah um no i don't know i
know
i know i've got a good question when
amir starts looking off in space and
scratching the back of his head i'm like
all right
i'm like staring at my bookshelf right
now because it's right in front of me
oh man i could say my favorite book of
2020. okay
um educated which is i don't yeah do you
guys know it i can't think of the
author's name but um
paulina was telling me about this she
said it's fantastic yeah yeah
phenomenal phenomenal read about um a
woman growing up in in idaho
in an incredibly conservative and
religious family and kind of
her journey out of that a lot of amazing
lessons
gosh i i probably have to say the
autobiography of malcolm x
is still at the top of the list for me
after all these years
um i i still think about it a lot
the journey of that of that man in
particular and all the twists and turns
it took so
i i think that's still number one for me
it's a very difficult yeah it's a very
good question
i should have been prepared for it but i
need like a week to think about that
so i'll send you an email all right
second one's
easy uh easier and more fun one aliens
are you a believer or non-believer i
believe in life
on other planets like yeah yeah okay
one one thousand percent not like the
green alien that yes of course
yes absolutely but somewhere out there
there are there's other intelligent life
yes somewhere yes yes awesome
where can i send people to uh to find
you guys on the internet or
find out more about your work at the
information
just www
yeah and i'm at kate clark tweets on
twitter
awesome all right guys thank you so much
for watching thanks so much
thanks for having us